but we do have things like TIMIS certification and stuff like that. Is that something?
Correct. But that's the kind of stuff that I feel is on us, because that's our tech stack. So, you know, that's where it would be on us. And so the career development plan was put together with things that, and the way that I look at a career development plan is, this is what's going to go with you after, you know, we part ways one day.
It is on OK.
Okay.
Mhm, mhm.
And this is your resume material. This is you, you know, you know, being able to get a raise and because you're operating at another level.
Mhm.
So do we have any part of that CDP to be able to say we'd like him to get this certification or something like that?
Correct. So all what you see on this CDP was put together, you know, a number of conversations, you know, with Dave about, okay, we want to be able to keep on a Microsoft path. And then of course, the Microsoft certifications are also part of our partnership level, which, you know, is something everybody needs to be able to participate in because you need one of,
Okay.
Mhm.
Mm.
you know, column A and two of column B in order to be certified as a whatever the hell they call it this year.
OKK.
Right there, always changing that up.
And, you know, and these become, you know, the core, the core kind of things. So, you know, we saw as we went through the, you know, the 900 exam, I mean, I took it and I'm like, damn, yeah, I learned a couple things right there. So, you know, being able to go through the solution set, we are very much
Mhm.
You know, a Microsoft Chopra.
I see 300.
So the next one that he would be working on is the SC 900. And so like we have above there, it's like what I would expect from ITBD is help him now get from here to November. So he should be working on some of those modules every month.
900.
Yes.
Mhm.
Yeah.
So, back to be able to see in the CDP, you know, a target that here's the ones that he's going to cover this month, knowing what he's also going to be covering from a from a study standpoint, as we have, you know, work situations that involve that topic area.
Mm-hmm.
We can also, you know, steer those kinds of things to him because it's like, hey, you're studying the, you know, blah, blah, blah, so here, go shadow Dave and he's going to be doing that.
Mm.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah.
Sense.
Thank you, Linda. Your message is acknowledged, and thank you for explaining it. Once again, we'll get it and we'll work on it.
Nice, nice, nice.
And if you don't mind, I started the transcript in between. I just didn't want to cut you, Nasa, because I just want to make sure I don't miss anything. So thank you for sharing that. Regarding the network piece, if I expect him to design.
Kip.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
a few models for you guys. Does he have, he knows who to connect with?
Design is a different, here's the thing, design is a different aspect because what we have is, here's the network. How does it go into a piece of software like Vizio or, you know, any piece of software that does it? How does the, what is expected of a person? Because our newly, so when we bring on new clients,
Mhm.
Mmh.
And when we send people for network changes, people being myself or Brian or some of our other people, and we say, okay, they take photos, they make a narrative of what was changed. And then the expectation would be for a new client, well, we have nothing. Start a chart, you know, we know we put in this, we know we put in this.
Mhm.
Mmh.
Mm.
And it is usually a very collaborative with the person who has been on site. And we also have a lot of charts, right, that, okay, there was a change made. The firewall was moved here or whatever. And so we would hope that in the future, and they could look at the chart and say, okay, I understand this network.
Mhm, mhm.
Mhm.
and I understand that he went on site to make a change to this piece and then that, you know, he can move the lines around or whatever. So it's really network architecture understanding rather than design. I would put design into a higher category, you know, as I am doing that design, of course, and now we have Carter's also.
Right, right.
Mhm.
Connect.
The whole, right?
Yes.
Mhm.
could be doing that design and that a person like Nick we would hope to be able to hand over was really documentation when it comes down to it.
Alright, so, so I got a great example. So, recently, where we we had hardware-based backups.
Mm-hmm.
Well now, as those are dying, we're replacing it with a pure cloud backup solution. So he goes in, he changes it to Kaseya EBDR. And so to keep the network diagram up to date, you need to be able to go in there and eliminate, you know, the fact that there's no longer a piece of hardware and then add a little cloud that the backup's going over there.
Mmh.
Mhm.
Like.
Mm.
Right. Makes sense.
Because that one page network diagram is what a tech uses when they're what I call parachuting into a client who they may not be working with day in, day out. And it's like, okay, let me understand this darn thing.
Mm.
Mhm.
Ketan.
You know, what are the, what are the basics? Where, where's their email? Where's DHCP? Where's DNS? You know, what's is this a little network? Is this a big network?
Right, right.
Okay, I have a few queries, Linda, Nasa, for keeping the network diagrams you are using Visio or anything else Visio. Okay, #2.
Lucid, lucid charts.
We use, yeah, Lucidchart is the online method and that's because it has an IT glue.
Okay.
connector and we use IT glue. And so again, it's really...
Bajaj it.
And it's much cheaper than a Vizio license.
Well, that's true too, probably. But it also has a wonderful connector to IT Glue. But really, it is a matter of documentation in that case. So he, Nick is doing the conversions from the hardware backup to the cloud backup. He's got that, he's already been doing that. But then he has to hand that over to somebody, you know, to do the, I don't know if there's any changes, you know.
Okay, right.
Okay.
all I know is the backup is working. And we're like, okay, thank you. We'll take over from there. But yeah, to give him the entire piece would be to also get him to understand the network diagram. And it's pretty standard stuff too. So I think as a development element to his education, it's only going to benefit him, you know, in the long run.
Right, right, right.
Okay. We don't have very many big, complicated clients. You know, most of, you know, our sweet spot, you know, is the, you know, the 10 to 30, you know, maybe 40, and then we have a couple larger ones that'll change over over time, but that's how you, you know, you progress.
Thanks.
Right.
Mhm.
True.
Got it. And how frequently changes are required in diagrams and how frequently new discovery is done.
Mm.
I mean, we're running.
60 clients. So, you know, everybody has some kind of a change two to three times a year. So, equipment swap outs, this, that, and the other thing. But like I said, you know, it's the basics.
Mhm.
Okay.
Got it. Yeah, I just want you to understand how frequently he needs to do that so we can put priority on that task on. So that's right. Thank you. Thank you for answering the query.
Right.
Yeah.
Mm.
Yeah, yeah, no, no, no. I mean, I even, you know, for us, when it comes to basic charting, our interns, that's one-on-one for the intern.
Shh.
Right, got it. We made a bit of it, and we'll work with Mick on this.
Yep. And like I said, he's smart, he's dedicated, he's hardworking, but just a little bit of structure. And that's what I'm looking for you guys to offload for me. Otherwise, I might as well just, I mean, that's what I need to be doing with my own people.
Kour.
Yeah.
And that's what makes them then a hire.
Right.
Perfect. A lot of clarity there. Thanks. Thanks for that, Linda, and thanks for joining today's call. So I will be quickly sharing my, yeah, I'll quickly, I'll walk you guys through the deck real quick. Just a sec. Hope the screen is visible.
Oh, we didn't even get to the deck, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yep.
Yeah, I see it.
I'll dive right into it. The agenda would be the key metrics, the highlights, utilization, trend and analysis, ticket closure, trend and analysis as well, and then way forward. We'll quickly go through the highlights. I'll walk you through what I've mentioned here, consistently high utilization. He maintained 88% billable utilization
month to date across 21 working days in the month of April. That's well above the 80% target that we have for him. Outstanding ticket closure, wherein he worked on 281 tickets and was able to manage to close 267 out of them. A 95% closure rate. Security alert management, managed multi-client Chrome security alert across water, CMID clients, and others.
Windows 11 upgrade project led coordinated build upgrade rollout across multiple clients, Waters Construction, Carlson and Carlson and Royal Flush. Onboarding and offboarding completed onboarding for EU.
Uh, help me with the pronunciation. It was, it was you, sorry, how do you pronounce that?
Kip.
I have no idea. That's a company that's probably got 100 people that are sitting on oil rigs all over the world.
Ault.
Yeah.
Okay.
Who, Petrocare?
Yeah.
No, uh, yeah, Patel Care, correct.
Okay.
So, I was sorry, didn't know how to pronounce that. Ustage. Ustage. Okay. Thank you for that. Right step mortgage, operating machines at Waters and Carlson, backup and monitoring, vigilance, proactively resolved data SAS backup failures, beam issues, and DESManagement alerts across NASA Point, Carlson, and Riverside Financial.
Eustace Hodge, Mr. or Mrs. Hodge.
Yeah, yeah. See, he's intimately involved with the backups for sure.
Yeah, and I'd say...
Yeah, so I'd say like the security alert management and the security alert management, he took self-initiative and figured out how to be able to, you know, do something with third-party packing in ConnectWise. And that's exactly
Yeah.
Bye.
you know, the kind of thing. It's like, okay, you see a problem, find a new, efficient way to fix it. And he grabbed onto that and did it. The upgrade project we had specifically assigned to him because it does require, you know, a little bit of leadership, a little bit of project management, a little, okay, you have to take the entire fleet and make sure that it goes from end to end.
Nice.
Mhm.
And so, like I said, so I find there that having to work with him to be able to break it down, it's like, okay, you can't just throw a build update at an end user. You need to let them know, because it turns out the darn thing needs 60 gig in four hours to be able to do an update.
Right.
Mm.
Nice, good to hear that. And there was one feedback that came up on the last call that we had, NASA, if you remember, wherein he was reaching out to you more than required. I did share that feedback with him, and I promise you I'm going to do that in a very subtle way so that he just...
Right.
It's not like he doesn't contact you anymore. It shouldn't happen. That shouldn't happen exactly. But do you see an improvement there?
Right, no, that that is.
I do, and I think, you know, we've had a little bit of a lull in, you know, complicated things. It's April, I suppose. But yeah, so I think Bhatia has also reinforced that, that overall, everyone needs to, you know, leave me alone, because I have...
Mmh.
Mhm.
different work to do. And so I think that he's heard the message for sure. And no, I don't think it stopped him from alerting me, but I think our goal is to get him to make posts in a general, so we have the general form of the tickets for him. So if it's a ticket he's working on, he might as well post it there.
Nice.
Yeah.
That way it's not just me. And I think he just did that 5 minutes ago. So that's great.
Nice, nice. Good to hear that. He's very positive with the feedbacks that I share with him, so I'm happy about that.
Great.
Huh?
All right, we'll look into the numbers real quick. Just the utilization bit to start with. 88%, like I mentioned earlier in the highlight slide. Total billable hours is 146.5. Non-billable hours, 20 hours. The target is 80% and he's been over 80% throughout the month. In the first week, he sat at 85%. Second week, 89.
89 again, 4th week 88, and then 89 again in the 5th week. If I quickly look into the ticket closures, he worked on 281 tickets in total, close to 67, 95% closure rate. There are 14 tickets that are still open and he's working on. Week on week performance in the week one that is...
Just had three days from April 1st to April 3rd. He worked on 54 tickets, closed 48 out of them, 89% closure rate. Second week, 35 tickets worked on and 35, he was able to close all of them. So 100% closure rate there. Third week, 73 tickets he handled, closed 71, 97% closure rate, highest ticket volume handled.
Mm.
Lang.
in the month of April. Week 4, 64 tickets worked on, closed 61, 95% closure rate. There was one PTO in that week, so working days was 4. In the last week as well, there were four working days in total. 55 tickets worked on and closed 52 out of them, 95% closure rate.
Hmm.
Mm.
That makes sense. So Linda, he's currently, he and I are splitting marathon. I do it two days a week, he does it, or no, I do it. He does it three days a week, I do it too. Yeah, I'm doing it Monday and Wednesday. And so as we're putting Carter in the mix for a marathon, these numbers might waiver a little bit because he won't have
Yes.
I.
Mm.
Marathon is Aarvin, but we'll see.
Yep.
Perfect.
Right. Thank you. Way forward, Windows 11, there are a couple of action items and open items here. Windows 11 pending upgrades, multiple upgrades tickets still open across waters, Carlson, Royal Flush and NAMI. Requires client scheduled windows. Onboarding in progress. Right step mortgage onboarding scheduled for May 4th.
Nassau point backup follow up. Backup agent issues had multiple entries, confirm permanent resolution and monitor in May. Xerox printer project, drum capital Xerox printer setup has been ongoing. Push for client decision or escalation. Plan forward for the month of May. These are the things that he's going to look into. Drive closure for all of all pending 25 is to upgrade tickets by coordinating client maintenance windows.
Oh yeah.
Mhm.
Complete right step mortgage, sorry, onboarding for you, sorry, Greg on May 4th. Continue proactive backup monitoring for data SAS and endpoint agents across all clients. Push from Capital Xerox Splinter project to resolution with client decision score clarification. Maintain 88% billable utilization utilization target heading into May as well.
Ohh.
complete data SAS migration, final verification across all orgs, monitor and close remaining open Chrome security alert tickets across client base. That's how the month of May looks for him, and I think that would be it from operations perspective, because the rest of the slides would be just information about the AI by design.
Team GPS, the ingrown product that we have, and that would be it. Before I open the forum for you guys, I think, Andy, do you want to, sorry I didn't include the build it slide here, but do you want to walk us through the upcoming event? And then I can hand over the stage to NASA and Linda.
Definitely. Although I'll be sending emails regarding the agenda because we'll be getting the agenda presentation next week. So I just wanted to brief you about Build It. That's basically from August 3rd to 5th. But on 2nd, we have a dinner for our partners at Kayla's that Sunny's mentioned.
Thanks.
Mm.
And on 3rd and 4th of August, that will be Build It! educational event completely. And on 5th, we have AIX later and we have a party at New York Stock Exchange in the evening. So that's for the first 300 registrants only. Have you already registered for Build It! or shall I send you the link?
If you could send me the link, I wasn't sure what my travel plans were going to be and where in the world I was going to be. So yes, send me it because I will be in the area up there. Because this year is in Jersey City, right?
Yeah.
Okay, yep. Okay, yep.
Right, right. And thank you, thank you with that. And Keith, when NASA started his story and I heard the world military, he has worked in military. So I forgot introducing myself because I started my career as a vendor for Indian Army. And what I used to do was there used to be a
huge bulky telex machine, Russian machine, and we used to replace them with a small laptop sized 8085 processor based telex machines. So I started my career with them and I used to love working with them because I used to stay there with them and there used to eat with them multiple places in North India.
I bet.
Ohh, my!
That's where I started my career and then moved to Dell, worked in Dell internal IT for 10 years and I have been working in IT by design since the last 11 years and recently moved to the customer experience team. And earlier this account was being managed by Sushant. He got promoted as a bench manager. So I got introduced.
Mm.
Wow.
Good for him.
Yeah, and I got introduced in the customer experience team. So my role is ensuring a good customer experience and I'll keep Keith bugging. Is this done? Is that done? That's my job. Thank you.
Okay.
Terrific.
Yeah.
OK.
There, you keep poking at me.
So Linda, do you have both Andy and Keith? I know I have Keith's email, but do you have Andy and Keith's email both on, you know, the stuff that's going around? I know I tend to just hit reply all and I don't really look to see who's on there, so.
Yu.
Yeah.
Yeah, that reminds me, Linda, whenever you drop an email, I'm not getting it and eventually Akhilesh forwards it to me because I'm not in the emails when you reply all today. So if you can add me there.
Ahh.
Ah, okay. I knew, see, I knew it was, yeah.
There we go.
Yep, okay.
So yeah, anything but CMIT, you can just drop an email to me and I'll be there to take care of things.
Okay.
Yeah, Keith will be sending minutes of meeting today, so he and me would be copied there. You can use that.
Perfect.
Yeah, you'll see your email addresses there.
Perfect. Then I'll update the thread. Okay. Perfect. My apologies for periodically looking off to the side. I have a, I have, I'm fostering right now, 3, 4 week old kittens. Yes. And my other cats are now starting to be able to say,
Yeah.
Cool.
Well, your cats, that's right.
Great.
What's this little thing crawling around the room? And so supervising to make sure that I don't end up with a cat fight.
Yeah.
The.
Ha ha ha!
Another interesting topic started. I love dogs and I recently brought 2 puppies from the shelter home. So I love playing with them.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly. All good. Okay, terrific. Thank you very much. And I look forward to those emails. Okay, take it easy. Bye-bye.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you. Thanks, Linda. Thanks for joining in. Thank you, Nanta.
Right. Thank you. Take care. Bye-bye.
Ready, play then.
Bye, bye.